Sounds
Orchestra Situation that forces you to cast a spell
How is the 3-line battle
different from the 2-line battle?The 3-line battle is different from the 2-line battle.The 3-line battle is a talent that has been chosen by the God of War.When it
comes to the 3-line battle, it is possible to output more magical power than the Japanese battle.
Of course, that's not all.The
true form that lies dormant in the wand is awakened.The true
form.Ah, it is said that magic was given by God.
Awakening the power of the god that dwells in it, the
shape of the staff changes. This is the
consumption of the staff of God given to the great Rain Ames. Black
Partisan Sounds
Shield